Smouse ago let's pray and welcome to
crash'd tastic
a few days ago I played turbo dismount
and you both really liked it this might
just be fine you never know actually not
and you suggested crash tastic so here
we have Harry all right guess huh all
right let's fight so here's our little
nice angle he looks pretty happy I think
he's happy enough I bet he's
compensating for something
alright so level one you must go a
distance of 10 meters let's make it nice
and symmetric and then we put some
wheels here for a good luck all right so
all we have to do is move I guess go all
right
that worked pretty well did I make it I
guess not [ __ ] all right here we go
let's try this one all right go nail it
all right yes my vehicle is beautiful go
come on it's perfect
if oh if anything goes rolling in my
brother's just add rockets and you'll be
fine let's go go I think that's pretty
solid I okay there Bob
break a leg Bob next one get some air
you must reach a height of 10 meters
[ __ ] no problem all right we need to
upgrade our rocket machine it must now
go up all right - is residence here we
come oh no it come on I spent forever
building that it's it's sad that I spent
five minutes making this Bob who go to
Spain yeah did it work
yes
the need for speed reach a mat minimum
speed up okay all right let's get some
wheel on this baby once this baby reach
80 miles per hour we're gonna crash into
a wall took me a while to get a
reference all right next one you must
cross the finish line all right
how does it look like well that's easy
go hello that's a success slide it to
win it
what the hell is that you must cross the
finish line go oh no my Rockets just
[ __ ] left me damn it
can you do it Bob
there we go stop turning Bob Pizza [ __ ]
never god this is gonna work nice nice
Bob you look good
your robot cannot touch the ground you
must cross the finish line all right
that would be more difficult then how
about we just go oh [ __ ] Bob I know
you're Cylons checked but ah god damn it
babe
and Sears right because the weight isn't
balanced
this should be good right Bob you piece
of [ __ ] man all right let's just [ __ ]
hope this works I don't even know Bob
Bob Bob it said the NFL I've come on
come on Bob don't be so down we did it
come on shut up goddamn Bob okay you
must cross the finish line yeah baby
don't give up Bob hey you kids going
right with Bob go want adventures lives
I had probably death and suffering next
level robots cannot touch the ground
what cheer up for God's sake this lot
ton of stuff in life to be happy about
there's turkeys and boobs and bacon and
then there's boobs I don't know what
else you need to see Bob what the [ __ ]
what am I supposed to do here
Oh Otis mr. crashing hip go
see what what is its objective here it's
a little wart there don't worry about it
why is it only so hard to do this every
time
well I guess the ward has to go
yeah keep taking it your daddy [ __ ] next
level you must finish over there's a
jump that should be awesome
oh [ __ ] oh god we need to steer in this
one can I steer oh yeah I can't steer
it's so hard to follow what the [ __ ] is
going up oh god it's gonna be come on
Bobby can still do it it's coming
through there is that [ __ ] yes yes baby
oh baby yes big jack [ __ ]
it's difficult come on what why make the
corners don't turn too much your robot
cannot touch the ground
that's easy come here [ __ ] the hell
what ha ha ok head-on collision alright
but he's just oh ok oh no he fell out
[ __ ] getting tired of this design Oh God
Oh God
come on Bob die I'm glad you finally
find a friend that you like Bob Bob Bob
that's not what I meant
stop that's not Kristin Bob and this
should work come at me bro
come at me okay need some work come at
me bro [ __ ] come at me bro
that's not gonna do it all right how
about now I may be a little too heavy on
the front all right god this piece of
[ __ ]
I'm actually really taking this game
it's actually a lot of [ __ ] fun all
right now we're talking man ha ha ha ha
okay well I loaded my old one so let's
see how that [ __ ] sucks
we know Nick slow your minds can't touch
cinders they do that one
I'll just go away every time you'll
write say that you got it super easy
next one you're all my kind of touched
around you must cross the finish line
company i [ __ ] ass
that's never gonna work why did I waste
time craving that shift
alright let's do this this should work
like simple is usually good right come
on you can't lick come on can we do it
oh so close
come on come on this is gonna take a
while
I built this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] for
so long that's not bad
okay now we're talking now we're talking
now we're not talking anymore
now we're crying then I'm just terrible
this should be a little better god dad
is never gonna work
come on come on whoa whoa I swear to God
this is the dumbest idea come on you can
maybe do it
Oh God nice going all right easy does it
go come on okay let's see if this [ __ ]
works
come on baby come on baby oh [ __ ]
we are back with some more aesthetic do
a Patek do all right let's see how this
goes I'm sure this will go great
make me proud Bob why is he turning I
don't understand that it's so symmetric
what that's working no don't don't go
crazy on me don't go crazy
you went great yes never mind this could
work this could work this could work I
don't think that's how you're supposed
to do it but I'll [ __ ] take it next
level robot must not must stop in target
oh yeah
that won't work let's just go right away
what how the [ __ ] am I supposed to do
that this is what I like to call a
stupid [ __ ] idea let's go [ __ ] hi I'm
Peter hi and welcome to [ __ ] me oh [ __ ]
oh god okay this is a little more subtle
you can do it Bob come on Bob all right
let's see how this goes wrong direction
okay so we got too much weight in the
back let's give it more weight on the
front here we go
that's pretty good we're going straight
up at me Oh
go Bobby boom go Bobby go Bobby
Oh Oh fly on the wings of Bob [ __ ] Bob
well going where no Bob is Bob to be
falling my Bobby buh buh bah bah bah bah
this is 2 percent less rockets stay stay
stay for [ __ ] gay I goddamn it ah a
little more weight on top maybe I don't
[ __ ] know Oh
oh I'm gonna start working at NASA or
some [ __ ] like that
ooh damn how is it easy it's not easy
iris I'm gonna have to end this episode
here it's a really fun game if you like
you enjoyed watching I really appreciate
it
let me know if you want more hit the sky
comer with today I'll see you bros in
the next one stay awesome love you seal
doesn't have a deal and the people who
don't have a deal are usually not a seal